was there ever a time you wanted to give
up filmmaking
wow you know what i have to be in terms
of me wanting to give up filmmaking
i don't think there's ever been a time i
wanted to give up honestly i mean
there's always been
there's been hard times i mean there's
been times where i've
uh there was one time when i first moved
to la
and i literally lived in six different
places in seven
no i lived in eight different places in
six months
and there was one time when my friend
moved i moved with him
because i was just couch surfing i would
be here and i'd be here
so and then there was a time i lived out
of my car
right literally i was just living out of
my car and so
i've had some really hard times but i've
never wanted to give up
never in terms of and maybe it's because
i just went too far down that road
and i was like oh there's nothing else i
want to do but um
the vision of being a director and a
filmmaker has always been there
you know despite you know circumstances
yeah but i but i've had you know
looked out of my car i lived out of a
sound stage um
yeah i've i've yeah paid the price
and not that everybody has to do that
right
um but when you're you know when you
have a dream
and you're committed you know and that's
and it's something that you believe in
wholeheartedly then you'll do whatever
it takes
you'll do whatever it takes to make it
happen
so you were living out of your car and
were you still
being creative or at least attempting to
be creative no it was hard
to answer your question living out of my
car and being creative it was hard
and uh no i wasn't i was still writing
but it was hard and at some point um
i had to just find a job and that's when
i started to do the sound thing more
seriously
you know just to keep a roof over my
head you know people don't realize how
hard it is to be a filmmaker in l.a but
when you first get here
you don't know anybody it's tough and so
i had to get out of survival mode
right i had to get to a place where now
i have money coming in
i'm paying the rent i'm eating i don't
have to call home and
ask my mother for money for you know for
rent i had to
so so being in survival mode is a really
hard place to be
and uh but la is not it's not an easy
place
to break in it's just not you know you
come out here
a lot of people doing what you want to
do um more some more committed than
others
uh relationships take precedent a lot of
time but when you first get there who do
you know
right you're building your foundation
you're building your network
and so and that takes time it takes a
lot of time
my advice is sometimes when people first
get out here i'm like
you know sometimes before you even get
here if you're wherever you are
you know idaho or you know or oakland
california if you will
but you know to get a body of work write
scripts have four or five scripts
you know or two three or three scripts
don't just come out here one script have
two or three scripts
then come out here right then that way
you you're going to be struggling you're
going to be living but you've got a body
of work now you can kind of go out and
shop that
uh but but to do that while you're out
here it can be really tough
especially when you're struggling so
once you
got this stable job and you got an
apartment or
your roommate or whatever yeah then did
you did it happen
gradually or did you feel like okay now
now that i have something coming in
every two weeks or whatever this
paycheck
i can start writing and whatever yeah
yeah well i got to tell you i had i had
to get out of the
out of the place of i would meet people
and they would give me hope like i would
get my script to somebody and someone
like oh
i can do what i can do but then i had to
realize that a lot of people in l.a just
talk
right and so um and i would call home
mom i meant such and such or
or uh you know girlfriend if i had it at
the time oh
i guess got the script so i just had to
get out of that place
right and so now having done it for
a lot of years now um
i have ex i don't i take the expectation
off of it like i have hopes
that um everything is gonna happen but i
take the expectation
like meaning i'm gonna give this person
a script they're gonna green light it
we're gonna make it and it's gonna be
done
because that doesn't happen a lot of
times right
and if you always set yourself up for
that like oh it's gonna happen
then you're living in a constant state
of disappointment so i think the best
thing to do is just sort of give it to
somebody and release
give it to somebody you have high hopes
but don't be too attached
to it or the expectation right because
you may set yourself up for
disappointment
and a lot of people i know a lot of
writers i know go through a lot of
depression
you know i don't want to come out of the
house i want to talk to people and so
i'm not i'm not that kind of person um
but
yeah i've just learned to sort of just
release i mean put the effort
you know in the case of howard when i
gave him the script
and we started to talk about it i mean
it was a year later
i mean we developed that thing for a
whole year like so it doesn't just
happen like i gave it to him
piqued his interest he liked it but he
wanted to develop it right and he
developed it me not even knowing he was
going to make it
i mean it was never a promise or him
saying oh yeah you know if we get to
this place i'm going to give you the
money or i'm going to finance it it was
just
it was a cordial it was a great
relationship the script was becoming
better so i didn't mind the relationship
because he would give us notes and the
script would be better
so at the end of that process whether he
was going to make it or not i was going
to have a better script
so i was like there's a win-win for me
and then
but then at the end of that year uh he
felt really good about script and where
it was at in terms of
place and he said let's go ahead and
make it i think we can make it in
uh you know i think it was at that time
it was
maybe in august and he said we can make
it in november and he had another film
he was going to do before mine
and then he pulled the trigger on it
yeah i always think it's like a kiss of
death when somebody says especially to a
young person
i want to help you yeah and i don't mean
to sound negative but
you really do have to have your guard up
especially those those words yeah yeah
listen i've met with uh since i've
directed that film skin in the game i've
met with some big tv
directors right i won't even name their
names and uh but i don't go in there
thinking oh they're gonna help me
they're gonna put me on
you know that's that's what some people
young people like that term being put on
somebody's going to grab you you're
going to have some kind of wizard of oz
or
boom and now you're on and i just it
doesn't happen like that
a lot of times and then you have to ask
what's it in for that other person
sure you know like i generously give
myself to other people now i want
i want to help other people you know but
i know it's
because it's just part of who i am but
some people aren't built like that
some people you know i mean they may
give you one word of advice and that's
it don't ask me for nothing else
right and so and some people will go
beyond that
but so i i've just learned to kind of um
just take what people can give me you
know take
and to the point about meeting with
these directors i don't expect anything
from them hey listen the guys can tell
me
what helped them what worked for them
sometimes that's good enough for me
yeah yeah i know there was another
person that was upset because
they felt that the peers around them had
or the people around them that were sort
of peers
had made it and that person hadn't yeah
and they're upset they said
they won't help me yeah but at some
point i i
have to think that someone can't risk
their reputation
and just trying to pull up their friends
too well i've had that happen too and my
conversation around that especially when
it comes down to
uh well in general yeah it's a tough
thing to do because
um well
let me back up i'm gonna say what i
wanted to say so uh
when it comes down to black filmmakers
and women women filmmakers i admire what
abe was doing
you know like he was hiring women
filmmakers to direct for the first time
on her show queen sugar right and
by giving them a shot and some of these
women have done shorts but most of them
have done independent features but
nobody looks at them right
so then when they take meetings they're
saying at the meetings a tv meetings
that is i want to direct tv they're like
well have you ever done tv well it
becomes a catch-22
well how am i going to do tv if i've
never done it and how are you going to
give me a shot
if i've never done it but yet they've
done these feature films right
but ava is eliminating all that she's
giving women a shot
to direct qualified women now women that
have proven themselves you know
and but we can more of us can benefit
from that right
like especially for me
when you're talking about like i don't
use word minorities but when you're
talking about like
people that don't traditionally have a
shot and that have been kept out
of the mainstream right so then i think
you have to set up not just lip service
programs
but work with these people and if they
qualify to get them in
sort of creating this new pool of
filmmakers
if you will is that a lot of the
filmmakers she's reaching out to
have independent films they've done
shorts so they've done something so
they've qualified themselves on a
certain level right
and now she's giving them access to
directv
and now so when they go back to
producers in television and say
um and a lot of the directors by the way
have gone on sally richardson
you know uh cheryl daniel have gone on
to do television
beyond ava but she's given them that
start but these filmmakers um have all
paid dues
and i make i make that a specific
specific point because people don't want
to pay dues anymore
they just want to be put on they want to
come out to la
and they want somebody to just like a
fairy godmother
to just come in and say here or they
want to write one script
or they want to write two scripts and
say oh i'm ready you know
and it just takes more than that um
i've paid a lot of dues and i think that
people should pay dues you know and when
i say pay dues it's really about just
uh getting better at your craft right or
doing
you know sometimes you have to be an
assistant before you can be a writer
before you can be in the writer's room
right or sometimes you have to be uh you
know direct shorts before you can direct
the feature
right so it's about paying those kind of
dues um in my case
i don't even know if i look at it as
dues anymore is is more as just a
necessary
stepping stone to get where you want to
be like
i've paid dues but for me now it's like
climbing the mountain
now i'm here okay and now i got to get
to here and i'm grabbing here and so for
me just because i've
done an independent film i still feel
like i'm paying dues
like i've gone listen i've come a long
way i want to
applaud my efforts and the people around
me that have supported me
to do this feature film right but to do
another film
at another budget point is going to
require another kind of paying dues
so i haven't made it by any stretch of
the imagination right and what is making
it mean anyway
you know so i mean i mean i think we all
set our own
standard for what success is and so i'd
like to think that i'm successful at
this level in terms of
having done this feature film but
there's other milestones
and other goals that i want to set for
myself
you